Thieme Kardashian is firing back at  people who criticized her revealing to  your looks I want to wear things that  make me feel good about myself and still  feel sexy the mom of dude took to her  app on Monday to simply write quote I  have always loved Shearer I just don't  give a [ __ ] lol I can care less what  anyone thinks or says she also provided  readers with a list of where they can  purchase some sexy sheer outfits the  reality star has been showing off her  body in a ton of see-through Styles  lately like here snapped on the streets  of Manhattan just days ago I love that  game or this - the Harper's Bazaar bash  during New York Fashion Week and rocked  this sexy number MTV's Video Music  Awards last month you just gotta roll  with it